hey wir sind leicht wir sind live für
euch am Tag 2 für die Menschen in der
Ukraine im Krieg nachdem Russland das
Nachbarland angegriffen hat und nicht
wie sie sagen nur militärische Ziele im
Blick haben sondern wie wir gesehen
haben und wissen auch Wohnhäuser
getroffen worden sind und selbst vor der
Hauptstadt Kiew scheint der russische
Präsident Putin nicht Halt zu machen für
viele dort war es eine schlaflose Nacht
Explosionen waren zu hören aber zunächst
war es erst noch einigermaßen ruhig bis
die Meldung kam das russische Soldaten
mit einer Bodenoffensive nach Kiew
einmarschieren sollen eine unklare Lage
vieles lässt sich auch noch nicht
bestätigen die Menschen suchten auf
jeden Fall Schutz versuchten teilweise
aber auch die Stadt zu verlassen weil
niemand so genau weiß was kommt also
Schutz in U-Bahnhöfen oder manche
machten sich eben auf an die Grenze über
die Grenze der Ukraine in die
Nachbarländer die Lage ist
unübersichtlich und nach Angaben der
Ukraine will Russland die Hauptstadt IPF
einnehmen wir werden noch Gelegenheit
haben in dieser Sendung darüber zu
sprechen mit Menschen die in Kiew sind
aber auch mit Menschen in der gesamten
Ukraine denn darum soll es in unserer
Sendung heute gehen um die Stimmen der
Menschen der Ukrainerinnen und der
Ukrainer ich möchte noch auf ein paar
Punkte eingehen was heute noch passiert
ist es gab noch ein paar Meldungen mehr
denn zum einen gab es auch noch die
Meldung dass Putin das ukrainische
Militär zu einer Revolte gegen die
eigene Regierung aufgerufen haben soll
auch darüber werden wir sprechen
außerdem noch das hier Russland sagte
also man habe der Ukraine Gespräche
Angeboten in Nachbarland in Belarus in
der Hauptstadt Minsk doch die Regierung
in Kiew die soll diese Gespräche in
zumindest Belarus abgelehnt haben und
stattdessen Warschau in Polen
vorgeschlagen haben sollen ihr merkt
also am Tag zwei dieses Krieges die
Ereignisse überschlagen sich wir
versuchen das Ganze für euch einzuordnen
und in unserer Sendung auf jeden Fall
den Fokus zu legen auf die Menschen die
in der Ukraine aktuell leben und eure
Fragen und Kommentare dazu jederzeit im
Stream oder ihr könnt sie auch per Mail
schicken und bevor wir in die Hauptstadt
nach Kiew schauen haben wir jetzt die
Möglichkeit in den Westen des Landes zu
schauen wir können sprechen mit einer
Ärztin mitgenommen um genauer zu sein
mit einer Kinderärztin mit Olena
siegrenetzka sie lebt im Nordwesten der
Ukraine in der Nähe von Lemberg
Ukrainisch
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend sie sind also noch in der
Ukraine können Sie uns berichten von
ihrem Tag wie verlief der heute bei
ihnen herrscht Ruhe herrscht Chaos wie
ist die Situation
also wenn ich sage dass Situation
angespannt ist dann sage ich nichts die
Leute sind in erschrocken
raus war gestern das war erste Tag und
niemand wusste dass Putin und seine
Armee macht so wie die gemacht haben
deshalb das war Haus
da waren die Apotheken Supermärkte und
Tankstelle storniert aber heute
heute kann ich sagen dass
bisschen mehr Ordnung in Liebe also wir
bekommen die echte information
und erstens wenn wir
Alarmsignal hören dann müssen wir uns
irgendwo stecken also leider haben wir
in Wien keine U-Bahn deshalb jeder oder
fast jeder Hochhaus hat eigene Keller
Schutzraum und müssen wir dahin jede
Familie hat für sich selbst
sogenannte
notrucksack oder notrufsäcke eingepackt
und müssen diese notrufsäcke mitnehmen
in den Keller
wir werden gleich noch weiter über ihre
Lage auch ganz konkret sprechen wir
schauen uns aber erstmal eine
Zusammenfassung der Ereignisse von heute
an von volkertucheck
um 4 Uhr war ihre Nacht zu Ende Oxana
golenko schmeißt das zertrümmerte
Fenster in den Innenhof rund 300
Menschen wohnen in diesem Kiefer
Wohnblock die meisten Wohnungen sind
nach dem Bombenanschlag zerstört die
Bewohner geflohen
ich lag im Bett plötzlich gab es eine
Explosion und ich wurde drei Meter in
den Flur geschleudert
glas splitterte und ich hörte Geräusche
auf der Straße ich hatte Angst und kroch
über den Boden
die Bilder sind der Beweis dass auch
Zivilisten zu den Opfern gehören auch
wenn die russische Regierung etwas
anderes behauptet es seien nur 118
Militärstandorte zerstört behauptet
Moskau
dieses Video zeigt wie ein
abgeschossenes Flugzeug ein Hochhaus in
Brand setzt die Ukrainer sagen es seien
russischer Jet gewesen die Russen
widersprechen
ukrainische Soldaten mit
Maschinengewehren hasten durch Kiew sie
wissen putin will den schnellen Fall der
Hauptstadt ukraines Präsident selensky
fordert von der NATO und den USA ein
schnelleres handeln
heute morgen sind wir allein und müssen
unser Land verteidigen so wie gestern
die mächtigsten Staaten der Welt schauen
von weitem zu und haben ihre Sanktionen
Russland überzeugt wenn wir in den
Himmel schauen sehen wir das reicht
einfach nicht
bei Cherson im Süden des Landes eine
russische panzerkolonne wesentliche
Gegenwehr gibt es offenbar nicht Putins
Armee rückt weiter vor während sein
Außenminister mit Vertretern der
Separatisten Hochburgen spricht
Seitenhiebe gegen ukraines Präsident
Russland wollen nicht dass die Ukraine
von Neonazis regiert werde zu Gesprächen
sei Moskau gleichwohl bereit sobald die
ukrainische Armee die Kampfhandlungen
einstellen
wir haben es gesehen also von mehreren
Seiten wurde die Ukraine da angegriffen
sie sind im Westen des Landes sind
Kinderärztin wie steht es denn um die
medizinische Versorgung im Moment können
Sie den Beruf gerade weiter so ausüben
sich um Kinder kümmern Kinder versorgen
also die Patienten die dürfen nach Hause
oder so nicht so schwach schon sind oder
bisschen schon behandelt dann schicken
wir sofort nach Hause und fast jeder
Krankenhaus
fertig oder fast fertig zum
behandelnden Soldaten
ich lese in den Kommentaren auch schon
Fragen und Kommentare viele fühlen sich
wie hier Limbo Jones bei Youtube
machtlos ob es irgendeinen Weg gibt
Flüchtlingshilfe schreibt er in Polen zu
leisten oder in die Ukraine zu fahren
oder es gibt von Leas die Frage ob es
Spendenmöglichkeiten gibt ich frage sie
ganz direkt weil ihr
lebensgefährtsgefährte der ist ja in
Deutschland und der engagiert sich
selbst auch in einer Hilfsorganisation
für Kinder hope in der Ukraine was
können Hilfsorganisationen und
Privatmenschen gerade tun um zu helfen
natürlich können Sie spenden an die
Organisation und so werden die helfen
hautbesitzer der in Wangen ist dann
irgendwelche Hilfe nach der Ukraine
schicken vielleicht nicht jetzt
vielleicht bisschen später
aber die Organisation braucht diese
Hilfe diese Spenden und
was sind ihre größten Sorgen aktuell für
Sie ganz persönlich
ganz besonders ich habe zwei Kinder auch
und die stehen am Mittelpunkt für mich
deshalb muss ich kümmern um die zwei und
so
kann ich kann ich nichts
sagen haben wir nur Hoffnung dann das
morgen wird besser als heute war und
aber niemand weiß was kommt und was
bringt die nächste Nacht
ja und die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben die
Hoffnung nicht verlieren sie sagen es
das ist auch natürlich eines der Dinge
die besonders wichtig sind im Moment ich
danke Ihnen für das Gespräch Olena
sikarenska in der Nähe von Lemberg Lewis
in der Ukraine vielen Dank danke
und kurz vor dieser Sendung konnten wir
noch sprechen jetzt konnten wir die
Verbindung nämlich nicht mehr herstellen
mit der ukrainischen Autorin und
Verlegerin Katharina misschenko sie ist
in Kiew dort konnten wir Sie erreichen
tatsächlich in Ihrem Badezimmer denn das
hat keine Fenster das ist also
vielleicht der sicherste Ort so dachte
sie und wir konnten mit ihr kurz vor der
Sendung sprechen ich habe sie zuerst
gefragt wie die aktuelle Lage gerade in
KF ist
ja die Lage ist unterschiedlich in
verschiedenen Stadtteilen manche
Stadtteilen wurden ja mit
Boden angegriffen soweit ich verstehe
wurden die Raketen erstmal ab
fangen
abgefangen ja aber die einzelnen Stücke
sind auf die Häuser gefallen und es gibt
dann
Rationen in
[Musik]
zwei glaube ich oder drei Kiefer
Stadtteilen
hier also ich befinde mich nicht weit
von Regierungsviertel ist es ruhig
wir hoffen sehr dass das auch so bleibt
wir hoffen dass für die ganze Stadt und
ansonsten ist
Kiew ja wirkt etwas dystopisch muss ich
sagen
es ist sehr Stil sehr wenige Menschen
auf den Straßen
vieles ist zu
und
[Musik]
ja irgendwie ist es ja eine neue
zeitlose
sehr gefährlicher Realität ja es gab
auch sie haben das Regierungsviertel was
unmittelbar in Ihrer Nähe ist auch
angesprochen es gab heute Meldungen auch
tatsächlich ob es nicht die Truppen
Russlands ob Putin es nicht auch auf das
Regierungsviertel in der Hauptstadt
abgesehen hat gibt es dazu irgendwas was
man sicher bestätigt sagen kann oder was
bei ihnen in den Nachrichten gezeigt
wurde was bestätigt ist ja also wir
haben eigentlich gestern damit gerechnet
dass Regierungsviertel ein Ziel ist und
dass es hier Kämpfe geben kann oder
irgendwelche Beschüsse aber zum Glück
hat es nicht geklappt vielleicht ist es
auch Verdienst
des territorialen Schutzes und
es war möglich die
[Musik]
russische Technik und auch die
fallen diese Fallschirm
Soldaten
unter Kontrolle zu bekommen denn es war
glaube ich schon geplant dass viele
von den
Flugmaschinen landen und
dann in die Stadt rein können also
vieles wurde glaube ich schon
vorgebeugt sie und ich wir haben am
Anfang dieser Woche schon miteinander
gesprochen also bevor tatsächlich sich
die Ereignisse so sehr überschlagen
haben haben sie damit gerechnet dass
tatsächlich aber so schnell russische
Truppen also auch der Hauptstadt Kiew
nah kommen können nein nein das ich
das muss ich ehrlich sagen jetzt beruhig
auch meine
gewisse Leichtigkeit denn ich hatte
Freunde auch in Deutschland die
alarmierend waren und die mich gefragt
haben was möchtest du tun bleibst du was
für einen Plan habt ihr und wir haben
keinen Plan gehabt wir haben das Gefühl
gehabt wer
ja das ist unsere Stadt wir bleiben hier
warum müssen wir jetzt flüchten es ist
ja noch nichts passiert und diese
Sirenen gestern früh also das glaube ich
ja das ist
einer der stärksten Eindrücke in meinem
Leben es sind nur zwei Tage vorbei aber
wenn ich hier am Montag denke an unser
Gespräch und an den Alltag denn ich
damals hatte ist es wie das vergangene
Leben heute ist es ist alles ganz anders
obwohl es erstmal überhaupt nicht so
aussieht
ja und ich muss sie auch Fragen haben
sie mitbekommen haben sie überhaupt Zeit
dafür natürlich in all dem Chaos auch
teilweise die politischen Gespräche
mitzubekommen weil Russland sagt ja man
habe der Ukraine Gespräche Angeboten in
Belarus in Minsk aber die Ukraine hätte
das abgelehnt und hätte stattdessen also
Polen Warschau in Polen vorgeschlagen
haben Sie dazu etwas mitbekommen wie die
politische Diskussion ist und wie sehen
Sie die Chancen dass die Ukraine
vielleicht tatsächlich mit Russland ins
Gespräch kommen könnte ja zu dieser
diese bohlenvariante davon habe ich noch
nichts mitbekommen und die minzquariante
fand ich wirklich problematisch da
Belarus da wir diese Truppen jetzt von
Belarus auch haben also das ist jetzt
das zweite Land das uns angreift deshalb
finde ich das auch wahrscheinlich
gefährlich
dass unsere regierungsleute hinfahren
vor allem wenn es auch offen gesagt wird
dass die ukrainische Regierung und der
ukrainische Präsident ihre Ziele sind
und das sind die angeblichen Nazis die
vernichtet werden sollen
deswegen
finde ich das richtig wobei ich sagen
muss wenn Russland schon so angreift und
so gnadenlos ist und es ist ja eine Lüge
dass
Wohnhäuser nicht attackiert werden es
passiert schon zwei kleine Kinder sind
schon tot und es gibt viele Verwundete
und auch Erwachsene Zivilisten die tot
sind und also wenn er schon so weit geht
und so brutal lügt dann glaube ich nicht
dass jetzt in Minsk etwas wirklich
passieren könnte das habe ich da habe
ich noch nicht das Gefühl dass sie
bereit sind wirklich zu verhandeln und
was wird die ja sagen Sie bitte und was
ich noch sagen wollte zu diesem
politischen Gesprächen
ich habe mitbekommen ich weiß nicht ob
das stimmt das
in Deutschland über die Geschehnisse so
diskutiert wird als wäre die Ukraine
schon aufgegeben man hat sehr viel
Mitgefühl mit uns als
Opfer
dieser verrückten
ja Fantasie von Entschuldigung von Putin
aber irgendwie sind wir schon als Opfer
irgendwo begraben
also es gibt keine Intention zu sagen
wir müssen jetzt die Ukraine retten nein
diese Krieg muss sofort stoppen und wir
müssen alles tun damit das passiert ich
glaube dieser Zug Schockzustand ist
vielleicht nicht ganz vergangen und ja
dieses ganze Mitgefühl macht mich sehr
traurig ich bin natürlich dankbar dafür
aber wir sind noch da wir leben noch und
es wird so gekämpft und die ukrainische
Armee kämpft wirklich ja für uns alle
und wir spüren das und sie muss darin
unterstützt werden und wir leben noch
wir müssen unterstützt werden bitte
nicht vorzeitig nicht vorzeitig
trauern was erwarten sie von Deutschland
von Europa wie sollten die sich ihrer
Meinung nach gegenüber Ukraine Verhalten
es gibt
bestimmte Erwartungen die auch wo die
mersilienz gehen
[Musik]
Entschuldigung
artikuliert hat es ist dieses Swift
Geschichte also diese internationale
Zahlungssystem aus dem Russland
ausgeschlossen werden soll ja und soweit
ich weiß ist Deutschland eines der
Länder das
Einwände hat zum Schluss noch die Frage
an Sie was ist ihr Plan ganz persönlich
werden sie bleiben wollen sie die Stadt
verlassen wollen sie die Ukraine
verlassen was ist ihr Plan wenn ich
danach fragen darf
ja also ich überlege die Stadt zu
verlassen
und
vielleicht morgen das weiß ich nicht
wenn das klappt also diese Nacht bleiben
wir hier und das Land zu verlassen
möchte ich nicht aber
im schlimmsten Fall wenn wenn es anders
nicht geht dann ja
ich muss ich habe einen kleinen Sohn und
ja vor allem denke ich jetzt dran dass
ich ihn schützen soll
danke Katharina mischenko dass sie sich
in dieser schwierigen Lage gerade für
uns Zeit genommen haben danke für das
Gespräch ja danke Ihnen
und weil so viele von euch auch danach
fragen und ich es immer wieder gesehen
habe möchte ich euch gerne kurz zeigen
was es für Möglichkeiten gibt auch jetzt
ganz aktuell zu Spenden für die Ukraine
lasst uns mal gemeinsam schauen und zwar
hier bei uns bei
zdf.spenden.de gibt es also diverse
Möglichkeiten für euch ganz prominent
auch bei uns immer das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe da könnt ihr Spenden
und hier findet Ihr auf jeden Fall alle
möglichen ja alle Möglichkeiten für euch
wenn ihr helfen möchtet wenn ihr Spenden
möchtet so dann versuchen wir natürlich
immer so viel wie möglich in dieser
Sendung eigentlich alles für euch live
zu machen ich hoffe ihr habt Verständnis
dass an diesem Tag wo wir versucht haben
so viele Menschen wie möglich in der
Ukraine in dieser Sendung zu bekommen
mit ihren Stimmen nicht immer ein
Live-Gespräch möglich war deswegen würde
ich euch jetzt auch noch ein weiteres
Gespräch nicht live sondern
aufgezeichnet zeigen müssen was ich eben
kurz vor dieser Sendung geführt habe es
ist aber sehr spannend und zwar mit
so mit ihm konnte ich sprechen erst
Notfallmediziner im Stadtkrankenhaus
Nummer 17 in Kiew und er hat sich extra
kurz Zeit während seiner Schicht für uns
genommen ich habe ihm ganz am Anfang die
Frage gestellt wie die Situation in
seinem Krankenhaus ist ob es bereits
viele Verletzte gab
Donnerstag
zum Glück haben wir keinen ständigen
Zufluss
heute früher haben wir eine fünf
verletzte mit Schusswaffen also
spätschusswaffenverletzungen erhalten
aufgenommen verschiedenen all das das
waren ja auch am Armeeangehöriger
allerdings war auch dabei ein Kind 13
Jahre alt
und eine Zielperson und auch das Kind
haben sie wegen schusswaffenverletzungen
behandeln müssen
ja alle
durchwegs mit
schusswaffenverletzungen
verschiedene Stellen hat
am Extremitäten bzw Brustkorb
und wie ist das für sie derzeit zu
arbeiten im Krankenhaus wir haben
natürlich allen selbstverständlich
sofort auch entsprechende Nothilfe
geleistet
und das war natürlich
verwunderlich dass dabei ein Kind war
nach nicht bestätigen Angaben war das
ein Kind das seine Eltern verloren hat
durch ein Beschuss
das Kind bereits operiert und sie ist
gerade in es ist gerade in der Animation
schreckliche Meldungen aus Kiew was wir
von ihnen hören wie ist das unter
welchen Bedingungen können Sie derzeit
arbeiten wir haben Berichte darüber
gehabt dass auch in der Nacht und am
Morgen also Kiew unter Beschuss geraten
ist unter welchen Bedingungen arbeiten
sie
entsprechende Sirenen
und falls wir nicht gerade operieren
müssen wir natürlich uns in den Keller
begeben alles ansonsten wenn wir gerade
beim operieren sind müssen natürlich am
Arbeitsplatz machen bleiben
das ist natürlich erschwerte Bedingungen
für Sie es ist aber auch so natürlich
gibt es für sie einen Plan einen Plan B
einen Notfallplan wenn Kiew noch weiter
unter Beschuss geraten sollte wie können
sollen sie weiterarbeiten dann wenn das
passiert
wir bleiben hier wir bleiben hier und
nach unseren Möglichkeiten weiterhin den
Patienten hilfeleisten
wir
haben ja das Personal fast komplett
vor Ort wir haben auch Krankenschwestern
und eine freiwillige dazu bekommen hoffe
wir hoffen dass der es dazu nicht kommt
zur
großen Patienten strömen allerdings
ist jeder jedes
hände-paar Goldwert zurzeit wir werden
alle aufnehmen
hier
haben wir einen guten Vorrat an
Arzneimitteln
und wir hoffen dass die Situation unter
unserer Küche bleibt obwohl alles
natürlich und das Verstehen alle
hervorragend davon abhängt wie groß der
Strom der notbedürftiger sein wird
die mitromiasnikow auch noch noch haben
wir tatsächlich niemanden verloren von
denen die bei uns eingetroffen sind alle
gerettet
wir haben es gehört er hat zumindest
alle retten können im Krankenhaus bis
vor kurzem war auch was hier michalishi
noch in Kiew erarbeitet für das Büro der
Konrad Adenauer Stiftung dort hat die
Stadt jetzt aber verlassen ist geflohen
nach Riesner im Nordwesten des Landes
Nähe der Grenze zu Belarus schönen guten
Abend
ja guten Abend wir erreichen Sie jetzt
also im Nordwesten um genauer zu sein
ich meine auf dem Land oder im
ländlichen Raum wie ist die Lage dort
vor Ort aktuell
hier ist natürlich viel ruhiger als in
Kiew obwohl heute schon fünf Mal die
Sirenen geläutet haben diese Ränder
Luftangriffe es kam zu keinen
Luftangriff Angriffe aber ganz früh am
Morgen war auch der Flughafen von rivene
mit
einer Rakete getroffen ansonsten gibt es
viel weniger Licht in der Stadt es gibt
lichtmaske Maskierungen so genannt wenn
die Leute Licht abends ausschalten
sollen oder wurden darum gebeten und es
gibt viel weniger Leute auf der Straße
viel weniger Autos
ansonsten ist die Situation unter
Kontrolle und ruhig
ich habe hier eine Frage bei Youtube von
einem User er heißt sowas wie also
schwierig auszusprechen und zwar fragte
er sich was muss man sich unter Krieg
vorstellen wird die Ukraine zerbombt
werden Leute erschossen was haben sie da
jetzt schon erlebt tatsächlich was kann
man sich unter Krieg vorstellen
ja also Gott sei Dank habe ich nicht so
viel erlebt als ich noch gestern in
Kiefer da waren die ersten Raketen und
viele Leute haben auch die Explosionen
gehört
die andere Städte ich habe auch mal in
harakir gewohnt vor ein paar Jahren dass
es im Osten der Ukraine Heike wird
ständig mit russischer artillerita bombt
beschossen da gibt es ganz schwere
Kämpfe es gibt Kämpfe in
unterschiedlichen Teilen der Ukraine im
Norden im Süden also die die Russen
kommen aus der Creme neben Haar gibt und
natürlich in
Regionen dann jetzt kommt Johannes die
ukrainische Armee kämpft ich bin ganz
einverstanden mit der vorherige Rednerin
dass man soll nicht die Ukraine jetzt
aufgeben die ukrainische Armee kämpft
und versucht diese diese Angriffe zu
stoppen es kommt natürlich zu
Raketen
eine Angriffe auf vor allem auf
militärische Infrastruktur also die
Flughäfen und so weiter Militärlager
und es war auch ein Versuch eine
mitfahrsteuer Jäger ein
Flugbahn eine Flugbahn nicht weit von
Kiew Beschlag zu nehmen die haben aber
gescheitert und diese Flugbahn wurde
zuerst unter ukrainische Kontrolle
übernommen und dann zerstört damit es
keine andere flugjäger kommen
damit sie das vielleicht auch wissen es
gibt ganz viel Mitgefühl ganz viel
Solidar Solidaritätsbekundung bei uns im
Chat möchte hier ein paar Kommentare
kurz aufgreifen DW schreibt bei Youtube
ich kann meine Tränen nicht zurückhalten
und ich bin an 29 jähriger Mann das ist
mir die Tage öfters passiert und waren
Zeit bei Youtube schreibt wie kann man
als Ukrainer im Ausland da noch die
Nerven bewahren gleichzeitig den Alltag
bewältigen andererseits die Angst um die
eigenen Angehörigen auch darüber wollen
wir später noch ein bisschen sprechen
also sehr viel Mitgefühl und Solidarität
hier bei uns im Chat und ich würde gerne
von Ihnen aber auch noch wissen sie sind
ja dann aus Kiew aufs Land geflohen wie
lief diese ja diese diese Flucht diese
Reise aufs Land lief das reibungslos wie
war das genau
ja das war natürlich nicht so einfach
wie unter normalen Umständen aber ich
habe mit einem normalen Zug gefahren es
waren viele Leute drin die auch nach
Westen fahren wollten der Zug kam mit
sehr großen Verspätung wenn es mehr als
drei Stunden weil es an einigen Strecken
ganz langsam gefahren ist also die Leute
reisen mit ihren Kindern mit sehr viele
Sachen mit Kästchen mit Haustieren und
es sieht ganz schrecklich aus das muss
ich sagen auch die viele Leute die in
obernstation einfach gewartet haben oder
dann später übernachtet haben das sieht
ja also ich habe sowas nie in meinem
Leben vorher gesehen das sieht wie ganz
richtige Krieg und also für uns
natürlich also wir wir versuchen so
optimistisch und so stark zu bleiben wir
können aber ich glaube ich werde das
nicht überschätzen das ist ein kleines
Ende der Welt für uns hier als Leute in
der Ukraine und das im ganzen Land sie
und ich wir werden auch gleich noch
weiter sprechen ich möchte noch ein
weiteres Gespräch allerdings dass wir
uns gemeinsam anschauen könnten auch das
kurz vor der Sendung geführt das war
nicht möglich das live zu machen wir
haben jetzt nämlich schon geschaut in
den Norden in den Westen in die Mitte
nach Kiew ins Land und wir haben auch in
den Süden geblickt und zwar nach Odessa
dort konnten wir mit Julia hurrasedi
sprechen sie arbeitet in einem
Rehazentrum dort in Odessa und auch
natürlich sie habe ich zunächst mal ganz
am Anfang gefragt wie die aktuelle
Situation dort vor Ort ist
die Lage ist relativ unruhig und
schwierig
meine Stadt und das ganze Land
er ist gestern vor Explosionen
aufgewacht weil wir wussten das als die
konfliktgefahr besteht dass die überall
Gefahr besteht allerdings wollte das
keiner glauben bis zum letzten Moment
weil wir einfach den russischen Menschen
einfach so vertraut haben ja sie wir
wissen ja dass
Russen einfach friedlich demonstrieren
und werden ein vor der Polizei verhaftet
wir können hier sowohl das russische
Fernsehen auch das ukrainische empfangen
und die russischen Fernseher Sender
berichten das absolute Gegenteil von dem
was wir hier erfahren ich jeder weiß ja
was hier sind in Russland flaut-bad wird
ja das alles hier Faschisten sind Nazis
es stimmt in gar keinem Punkt wir sind
freilebend wir sind einfach
freiheitlich orientiert wir bitten alle
um Beistand um Hilfe bei uns sterben
friedliche Menschen zivile Menschen
unsere Hauptstadt bereitet sich auf
einer Verteidigung vor eine schwere
Verteidigung und wir haben Angst weil
Odessa auch angegriffen wird
wie war das heute wurde Odessa auch
heute morgen schon und letzte Nacht
angegriffen wie es die Lage zur Zeit in
diesem Moment
war alles seit heute Nacht war alles
ruhig
gestern früh wurden militärischer Objekt
angegriffen von der ukrainischen
nationalen Garderoben der
Armeeangehörigen der zu demoralisieren
die großen Städte ja der größten
militärobjekt hat waren das Ziel dafür
die Nacht war eigentlich ruhig und wir
sind heute früh aufgewacht und erfuhren
gleich das Kiew unter einer massiven
Beschuss steht wir haben auch russische
Reporter hier die vieles in den sozialen
Netzen berichten und alles weiterleiten
was Sie sehen was sie erfahren und das
entlarvt natürlich auch die Lügner in
Russland Gott sei Dank können wir uns
tatsächlich darauf vorbereiten was uns
erwartet einigermaßen
heute kam zum Beispiel die Nachricht
dass einige Straßen bzw Gebäude schon
bestimmte Markierungen erhalten haben
mit einem mit leutfarben und die
Bevölkerung wurde das so aufgerufen
diese Markierungen die eigentlich als
angriffsorientierung den Russen dient zu
vernichten beziehungsweise
zu so schwer und zur entfernen wir
hoffen dass wir auch durch unsere Hilfe
das alles Schreckliche verhindern können
es sterben Menschen das Sterben Kinder
und Mütter das war bei ihnen in Odessa
mit dem Markierungen
unter anderem unter anderem wurde auch
gemeldet dass
viele freiwilliger jetzt unterwegs sind
mit ihrer der eigenen Autos
und haben auch in der derzeit auch
dieser Markierungen entdeckt und das
wurde aus dem ganzen Land berichtet die
aufklärungsstruppen verteilen diese
Markierungen und dann ähm werden sie von
den regulären Truppen benutzt was ist
für die Angriffe ja was ist ihre
Entscheidung für sich selbst für Sie
persönlich wollen sie bleiben wollen Sie
wenn es noch schlimmer wird das Land
verlassen was ist ihr Plan
ich bin ja 29
ich bin ja nach der Unabhängigkeit
Erklärung geboren und ich habe nie
früher in der Ukraine so einen
Patriotismus gespürt wie heute ich bin
stolz darauf dass es hier leben darf und
ich bin stolz auf unsere Armee das sind
hervorragende Menschen entschuldigen Sie
ich sag mal es mir als der Youtuber und
meine ganze Familie bleiben bis zum
Schluss in Odessa und solange es nur
geht wir werden unser Land Verteidigung
und wir werden uns nie den Terroristen
beugen nie
Putin morgen wir bleiben zu Hause und
wir werden unser Land frei bekommen und
ich glaube ich habe noch nie zuvor mich
so mit einem Menschen in der Ukraine
verbunden gefühlt wir bleiben wir
bleiben hier das war meine endgültige
Wahl
sie brauchen sich für ihre Emotionen
nicht sicher nicht zu entschuldigen das
sind auffüllende Zeiten für Sie und alle
Menschen in der Ukraine ich danke Ihnen
dass Sie Ihre Einschätzung und ihre
aktuellen Gefühle und ihre Situation mit
uns geteilt haben vielen Dank Julia
horazidi in Odessa
al
danke ich danke Ihnen dass Sie darüber
berichten dass ihr das uns Gemütlichkeit
geben einfach die Wahrheit zu sagen
und dass sie sie bekräftigen uns in
unserer Hoffnung es lieber Ukraine
spüren Sie das auch diesen Stolz und
auch diesen Kampfgeist jetzt der
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine
ja absolut absolut die ganze
Gesellschaft ist mobilisiert es gibt so
viele Leute die jetzt zu territorelle
Verteidigung eintreten können wie nie es
ich bin stolz auf meine Armee ich bin
stolz auf meine Armee seit 2014 als
eigentlich dieser Angriff in die Ukraine
angefangen ist mit Annexion der Creme
und Intervention in der Ostukraine aber
jetzt das sind wirklich die Leute durch
durch die die Ukraine überleben wird
Stichwort Armee alle Männer im
wehrfähigen Alter die so heißt es dürfen
sollen können ja nicht mehr ausreisen
das gilt dann auch für Sie oder
ja das stimmt das heißt selbst wenn sie
wollten könnten sie das Land nicht mehr
verlassen und was haben sie da
beobachtet ich meine auch gelesen zu
haben das Waffen ausgegeben werden an
die Menschen in verschiedenen Städten
was können Sie uns dazu berichten
ja vor allem gilt das über Kiew ich habe
am meisten Fotos von Kiew gesehen und
Videos wo die Waffen verteilt wurden
weil die braucht Leute die sich
auskennen die militärische Erfahrung
haben und mit der Waffe in der Hand
bereit sind die Hauptstadt zu
verteidigen weil
wir verstehen alle dass Kief Hauptziel
von russischen Truppen ist weil die eine
der vermutlichen Pläne von Puten ist
eine neue Regierung in der Ukraine zu
machen eine
Marionetten Regierung die natürlich was
natürlich für die Ukraine sehr schlecht
wäre
ich habe dazu auch ein paar Fragen bei
uns im Stream und zwar fragt sich Sharon
Shannon bei Youtube warum kapituliert
die Ukraine nicht statt zu kämpfen ob es
Russland gehört oder Ukraine ist doch
egal hauptsache es sterben nicht mehr
Menschen schreibt die Person bei YouTube
es ist gar nicht egal ich glaube auch zu
Zeiten von Zweiten Weltkrieg es war
Großbritannien zum Beispiel nicht egal
dass sie zu totalitären nicht freien
Welt gehört die Ukraine möchten in einem
freien demokratischer Welt lieben die
Ukraine hat das
2013/2014 durch die Revolution der würde
gewählt und wir stehen fest auf diesem
Weg Russland ist alles was die Ukraine
nicht braucht Korruption schlichte
schlichte Führung
Polizei Gewalt und natürlich autoritäres
System ohne Demokratie ohne freier
Wahlen das ist das was ich für die
Ukraine gar nicht vorstelle
und noch eine weitere Frage die dazu
passt Thomas Borg fragt sich bei Youtube
was denken sie werden wird die Ukraine
bis zum bitteren Ende kämpfen oder wäre
es doch schlauer zu kapitulieren also da
auch immer wieder diese Abwägung
wahrscheinlich aus Sorge eben das
natürlich Menschenleben zu Schaden
kommen
wir haben auch natürlich sorgen dass
Menschen sterben und wir hoffen dass es
letztendlich zu einer diplomatischen
Lösung kommt aber ich hoffe dass diese
diplomatische Lösung wird nicht eine
Kapitulation für die Ukraine bedeuten
natürlich
wir müssen vielleicht dann später
irgendwelche Kompromisse machen aber ich
glaube man kann keine Kompromisse mit
Freiheit machen freiheit ist das wert
dass eigentlich keine Kompromisse
zulässt
neben der Solidarität für Ukraine auch
viel Sorge bei uns im Chat im Stream und
auch hier in Deutschland gibt es
natürlich viele Menschen die Verbindung
haben in die Ukraine Familie Freunde und
da haben wir einen Beitrag von Elisabeth
Schmidt in den wollen wir kurz
reinschauen und dann auch noch einmal
darüber sprechen
Kiew unter Beschuss heute morgen um 4
Uhr in deinem Haus wohnt meine Ecke sie
sind am Leben Taras lewtschenko hat
trotzdem schlaflose Nächte gerade haben
wir jetzt so ein rhythmus-fernbart dass
wir alle 30 Minuten dass ich wenigstens
einen Smiley bekommen und bei Whatsapp
das heißt Smiley hast du alles gut mir
wäre schon ausreichend wenn sie mal ein
bisschen in eine kleinere Stadt woanders
weiter westlich
da würde ich mich dann sicherer fühlen
besser schlafen sozusagen ob sie dann
nach Deutschland kommen dann sehen wir
weiter also es wäre überleben das jetzt
eigentlich der Punkt
Waffenlieferungen ein Gas embargo das
wünscht sich Taras lewzenko von
Deutschland und der EU zurzeit fühlt er
sich ohnmächtig oldena groszinas Familie
lebt in luchansk in der Ostukraine ihre
Verwandten wollen bleiben ihr Land
verteidigen
ich möchte nur dass dir am Leben bleiben
und natürlich ich verstehe die dir sagen
dass die gehen sogar kämpfen das ist ja
natürlich ziemlich
realistisch weil meine Mama 68 und meine
Schwester ist echt
Frau nicht für Kampf
Lilia und William dubbers sind beide in
der Ukraine geboren sie leben in
Oldenburg und machen sich große Sorgen
um ihre Verwandten und Freunde in der
Heimat
die werden jetzt einberufen es ist eine
general mobil machen ja sie wird ein
Berufen wohin mit den Kindern vielleicht
muss ich mich gleich ins Auto setzen und
muss an die polnische Grenze fahren um
diese Kinder abzuholen
im Moment sind sie nur mit ihrem Körper
in Deutschland sagen die beiden mit
ihren Gedanken sind sie in der Ukraine
neben allen Menschen die verwandte
Freunde in der Ukraine haben denken
natürlich auch wie wir lesen es hier
wirklich im Chat auch alle hier in
Deutschland sehr stark an die Menschen
dort aber die Frage auch an Sie ganz
konkret was wünschen Sie sich von der
deutschen Bevölkerung von der deutschen
Regierung jetzt in diesem Moment für
Ukraine
ich glaube es gibt
ganz konkrete Wünsche vor allem ist
natürlich Abschalten von Russland von
SWIFT System Bankensystem
schwere Sanktionen im Bereich gastran
sieht oder Gas Ankauf und Lieferung von
Waffen an die Ukraine Polen zum Beispiel
hat das bereits gemacht die erste Waffen
aus Polen sind schon eingetroffen das
ist die Geschwindigkeit die wir jetzt
brauchen weil jeden Tag ist entscheidend
vielen Dank für Ihre Eindrücke von vor
Ort vielen Dank dass Sie mit uns
gesprochen haben was sie mir halicin
habe ich das richtig ausgesprochen zum
Ende Michael Schienen so glaube ich ja
danke Ihnen
und ja ich werde jetzt euch tatsächlich
auch damit in die Nacht entlassen ich
habe eure ganzen Nachrichten gelesen
möchte vielleicht noch einen Kommentar
auch zum Ende aus noch mal rausgreifen
der vielleicht ausdrückt was viele von
euch denken Wert Brezel bei Youtube
schreibt ich hoffe dass das Ganze
schnell vorbei ist für die Ukraine und
für Europa es gibt niemals eine
Begründung Krieg zu führen danke dass
ihr zugeschaut habt und bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss